CLEARER.
YET, THE SAME GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS WHO FAILED TO
PROTECT US ARE SAYING WE
DON'T HAVE A RIGHT TO
PROTECT OURSELVES.
MICHAEL GRAHAM AT THE S. A
BOSTON HERALD COLUMNIST AND
MICHAEL IN THE MORNING
PODCAST RICOCHET.COM.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT TO
ASSESS THIS CASCADE OF
FAILURES AND THE
SELF-RIGHTEOUSNESS THAT HAS
FOLLOWED.
THIS SEEMS LIKE THE BIGGEST
CASE OF DEFLEXION ON RECORD.
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS RATHER
THAN STOPPING AND SAYING YOU
KNOW WHAT?
WE SCREWED UP AND WE ARE
GOING TO FIND OUT WHY ARE
SAYING AMERICA, IT'S YOUR
FAULT.
>> YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU LISTEN
TO YOU RECOUNTING ALL THESE
EVENTS, OBVIOUSLY THE
CULPRIT, TUCKER IS THE NRA.
IF ONLY THE NRA WERE
DESTROYED THEN WE WOULD
SOLVE ALL THESE PROBLEMS.
I LOVE THIS ARGUMENT THAT WE
ARE NOT COMPETENT ENOUGH TO
OWN GUNS TO PROTECT
OURSELVES BECAUSE WE ARE
STEW STUPID.
WE WILL SHOOT OUR EYE OUT,
WHATEVER WE HAVE TO RELY ON
GOVERNMENT.
OKAY HOW ABOUT THE
GOVERNMENT?
ACTUALLY THEY ARE OUT IN THE
PARKING LOT HIDING WAITING
UNTIL THE SHOOTING IS OVER.
CAN I HAVE A GUN?
THAT JUST PROVES THAT GUNS
DON'T WORK.
HEADS I WIN TAILS YOU LOSE
ARGUMENT FROM PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO RESTRICT GUN RIGHTS.
>> Tucker: SOMETHING IS
GOING ON HERE THOUGH.
I STILL HAVE RESPECT FOR,
AFFECTION FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
I KNOW A MILLION OF THEM.
GREAT PEOPLE PROTECT US HERE
AT FOX.
GRATEFUL TO THEM.
HERE HAVE YOU APPARENTLY
ACCORDING TO REPORTS TONIGHT
FOUR SEPARATE ARMED COMING
OR DEPUTIES, SHERIFF'S
DEPUTIES REFUSING TO GO IN
YOU CAN'T TELL ME ALL FOUR
OF THEM ARE COWARDS.
IS THERE A POLICY?
YOU THINK AT LEAST ONE OF
THEM WOULD HAVE GONE IN.
WHAT'S THAT ABOUT.
>> A NORMAL PERSON CANNOT
STAND THERE WITH A GUN AND
LISTEN TO KIDS GET KILLED
WITHOUT RUNNING IN THE DOOR.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> I WROTE A PIECE FOR THE
FEDERALIST TODAY GOING BACK
AND LOOKING AT OTHER
INCIDENTS WHERE THE COPS
STAYED OUTSIDE.
PEOPLE FORGET THE ORLANDO
MASSACRE WHICH WAS THE WORST
SHOOTING IN MODERN AMERICA
UNTIL LAS VEGAS, THE COP
ACTUALLY SHOT -- GUN
EXCHANGE WITH THE KILLER.
THE KILLER GOES IN COP STAYS
OUTSIDE.
SWAT SHOWS UP.
THREE HOURS WHILE MURDERS
ARE GOING ON INSIDE.
IN NEWTOWN, ACCORDING TO THE
JUDICIAL REVIEW.
COPS STOOD OUTSIDE FOR FOUR
OR FIVE MINUTES LISTENING TO
THE GUNFIRE AND DID NOT GO
IN THE BUILDING.
SO THERE ARE TWO BRANCHES
HERE.
ONE IS COWARDICE, I THINK
THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT TO
MAKE THAT POINT.
THE OTHER IS TRAINING THAT
DEPARTMENTS STILL HAVEN'T
FIGURED OUT HOW THEY ARE
GOING TO DEAL WITH THESE
ISSUES.
COLUMBINE WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
THE TURNING POINT.
WE KNOW PEOPLE WAITED
OUTSIDE AT COLUMBINE BECAUSE
WE HAD NEVER SEEN A
COLUMBINE.
IT'S KIND OF LIKE 9/11.
YOU CAN'T BLAME PEOPLE FOR
NOT UNDERSTANDING 9/11 WE
HAD NEVER SEEN IT THIS IS A
POST 9/11, POST COLUMBINE
MOMENT.
JUST AS PEOPLE ON AN
AIRPLANE WILL NEVER SIT AND
WAIT FOR HIJACKERS TO TAKE
THE PLANE ANYWHERE.
POLICE SHOULD NOT WAIT FOR
PEOPLE TO DIE INSIDE THE
BUILDING.
THE ARGUMENT GOT TODAY AND
HEARD FROM A LOT OF POLICE
OFFICERS TODAY.
YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND,
MICHAEL, IF WE GO IN, THERE
WILL BE DANGER THERE IS A
GUY WITH A GUN IN THERE.
THERE ARE DEAD PEOPLE.
THE DANGER PART IS ALREADY
COVERED.
SECOND, THIS IS TRULY
DISTURBING.
I'M WITH YOU.
MY UNCLE IS RETIRED LAPD,
WEIGHS HONORED FOR HEROISM
TWICE.
HIS BROTHER WAS A DEPUTY.
I HAVE LAW ENFORCEMENT IN MY
FAMILY.
THE VAST MAJORITY WANT TO DO
THE RIGHT THING.
THE NUMBER OF POLICE
OFFICERS WHO HAVE TOLD ME
POINT BLANK MY NUMBER ONE
JOB IS TO GO HOME SAFE AT
NIGHT TO MY FAMILY, AND THEY
POINT TO A SUPREME COURT
CASE THAT SAYS THAT POLICE
DO NOT HAVE A DUTY TO
PROTECT YOU.
IF THAT'S YOUR NUMBER ONE
JOB TO GO HOME SAFE AT
NIGHT.
YOU NEED TO FIND A MALL THAT
NEEDS A SECURITY GUARD AND
DO THAT FOR A LIVING.
THE REASON WE HONOR COPS IS
THAT COPS DO THAT AMAZING
THEY SEE DANGER AND THEY SEE
AN INNOCENT PERSON AND
THEMSELVES AND THEY SAY I'M
GOING TO CHOOSE TO GET
BETWEEN THE INNOCENT PERSON
AND THE BAD GUY.
THAT'S WHY WE HONOR COPS.
WE DON'T HONOR COPS BECAUSE
THEY HAVE THE BEST POLICY
SIT OUTSIDE THE CAR WAITING
FOR THE SWAT TEAM.
>> Tucker: IF THEY DON'T
WANT TO PROTECT THAT'S FINE,
DON'T PREVENT US FROM